dang the last chance to see the ru
garbage live show is upon us it's to mix
of stand up comedy plus we play the
little a with the crowd yeah the last
shows of the year are December 14th in
Washington DC at the Howard Theater get
the homies get the boers let's see you
there then we're doing uh two On's
already sold out in Philadelphia at the
Filmore limited tickets left for the
second show at the Filmore that will
sell out let's get those tickets let's
party baby scoop them up love you
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's our little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
at they group to be classy or they just
a big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toies in the new edition the
holiday spirit is in full swing she's
upstairs trimming the tree okay with the
manscaped you know what I'm talking
about getting it tight for the mail man
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is international businessman and he
works in the wild wild west give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you R you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are cooking baby then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com garbage gang check it
out it's a freaking party over there yes
sir and how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinary the old
magic man works the ones and twos the
threes and the fours he crosses the te's
and he dots the eyes give it up for
T-Bone MC scruffing Toby MCM and
everybody what up boys what do you say
pal I'm trying to get into a mosh pit we
got the best dude in the world in here
man one of my favorite guys all time
guys all time Duty makes you makes you
want to get Rowdy and have a nice time
had to bring him back quick to run it
back I know cuz I think we we I think we
got the age seven before with them and
that took 90 minutes so far we have uh
we have parents married young quick
divorce we have a step wedding next door
to where you live shout out to
Susan I have no problem with Susan
Baltimore vacations you know can I tell
you cuz I'm sure time Susan's house also
she uh one time my mom was hanging out
with Susan and up in her she goes to go
go watch TV up in her bedroom and uh
the movie there's a Cinderella
movie um that was on Cinemax that was
like a softcore okay I'm listening but
about a snapping I believe snapped and
she had to find the one guy who like
fitt it or whatever and uh I think it
was one of my first uh I don't think I
finished I think I was too young but
definitely like slapped it around a
little bit up in that room hoping nobody
was coming kicked the tires a little
yeah was a little I was a little young
for anything to come out but I mean if
we're counting ghost loads G's
gang we're so excited to have our
incredibly special guest back with us
again as we said he has an amazing
special out dog belly that you got to
check out creeping on two million views
over there on YouTube he's the host of
legion of skanks the host of SDR and a
host of the bonfire and the only guest
to ever use the word stool
pigeon give it up for the one the only
big J oerson everybody you know it's
funny as you describe the show where you
bring in your favorite Comics to find
out if they were uh grown up to be
classy or garbage is this the first time
you bring me back just to find out how
gar it's already we've confirmed on
garbage how far we we're just digging
for more this is more of a sentencing I
I got to tell you what and this is why
it's such a great show there's almost no
decision I make in my life that I have
to think about for two seconds where I
don't go it goes is this more evidence
uh I was in I was I love how we're just
in the back of your head at all times
I'll tell you what I still usually go
through with it sure yeah course you
don't know any different went to uh
Philly
mhm two weekends ago to do the casino
out there m and on the way home I
stopped by a store to get my dog at Joel
andb
Jersey and seven I mean easily 17
lighters okay that all have like Sixers
on them or Eagles cuz you can never get
those up here at all so I get I get my
years worth of eagles and dude if you're
buy I get a pink one for the lady
there's a pink one that the lady has I
go you put this in your
purse dude anybody buying lighters in
bulk that's nuts the lady couldn't
believe it cuz she has to scan she had
to turn them all on their backs I just
like you know poured them out of my
shirt and she had to turn them all on
their backs and like go through and I'm
like Miss just count them and do one a
bunch bet you don't get this many Rich
guys coming through here huh
lady Big Spenders com much is that
replica h i mean if I had a h that's the
D thank God I have an apartment still
cuz if I had a house like the amount of
unnecessary trashy memorabilia not
really like emotional to me memorabilia
but I'll have it up anyway my mom for my
parents don't to get me for Christmas
ever MH they never know but the stuff
they do get is great I've gotten uh
Carson Wentz picture book okay I have
hanging in my closet cuz there's no more
room on the walls uh an autographed
framed picture of Brandon grah I'm
sacking Tom Brady is Super Bowl that's
pretty good yeah but I mean it's
supposed to it's supposed to be hanging
up like in a sports memorabilia store no
one ever buys it bu that yeah the kid of
the owner of that store gets that
eventually fulls siiz cat out of Doug
Peterson in a Jaguars jersey oh if I had
a house with like a marble entrance it
would be the Rocky statue and the statue
of uh of Nick F Doug Peterson giving the
Philly Philly
call that would be in my
foer right before the grand staircase
pay your respects to Philly Heroes two
great there's something so funny about B
bur yelling at a crowd lead in bronze
there's something so funny about framing
a defensive play like this is your this
is your uncle going defense wins
championships the famous One my brother
got it autographed when we were kids is
Chuck bck taking out uh gford yeah yeah
yeah yeah he like broke his back yeah
yeah yeah it was uh I when I went on Ron
and Fez uh the old radio show Ron and
Fez the first time uh I won some thing
from their prize closet and it was a a
poster of that moment of Chuck bed and
Eric knocking gford out yeah concrete
Charlie his hands were all broken dude
nuts different breed back then but oh
that's yeah that's when your white guys
were gigantic white guys sure you no one
even was wasn't even offensive to go
that big Po's coming through the
line clubbing you oh man tting you up no
always had those big cast on too yeah no
definition at all
just [__] dad bods but like enormous
dad bods cigar hanging out of the helmet
yeah [__] white guys built like
tongin so when we last left you yeah uh
you were driving hookers yeah which is
where we were at yep and slowly and
slowly falling in love oh with the first
girl I drove Candace cuz you wear your
heart on your sleeve you're a bit of an
emot did I tell you though that when I
drove her a years later like two years
later I think you might have yeah yeah
like drugs got her so she came out and
she was like I drove her and another
girl and she was like the joke of the
party and I felt a weird ownership over
her still not that old I lit they were
like they're like yo why is that girl so
pasty and her [__] so Brown I'm like
look while you're not wrong I know her
potential she can get it back dude you
don't know her like I know her you
should have saw her two weeks ago it was
just some hot Asian did I tell you the
stripper story when I drove how long did
you do this for on and off like year and
a half two years year and a half two
were you you weren't doing comedy yet no
I was doing comedy and that's what I was
like an easy way to make I wasn't doing
comedy on the weekend when you first
start you're doing like Tuesdays and
Wednesdays and Thursdays are your Open
Mic nights uh different places and um so
the weekend I had nothing going if I
wasn't going to one of the nights I
would go to the laugh house to watch
like whoever the headliner was sure CU
you can go for free at that point sit in
the back yeah and then uh and one of the
other days or two of the days I would
any days I was off I would take like
this job driving escorts and strippers
escorts is easier because they go and
like the the guys are getting what they
want sure generally it doesn't always go
great but I've driven uh I was so not
prepared for the job said the guy asked
me if I had a gun I was like no he's
like do you want one I was like
no I'll pull that out way
early it's so scary when they start like
turning on you what do you mean she
doesn't [__] like okay
fell your move is to put it to your own
head I'll do it I swear to God I us ruin
your floors I used to go we have your
credit card we have your credit card we
have your credit card and they be like
all right man but we really thought she
was going to [__] I
go she's not this one's actually putting
herself through
college um but the uh one time I drove
what ended up being they go uh and they
said the guy was L he never cared like
how dangerous s goes meet us at this
liquor store cuz you'll never find it
and they a white van pulls up next to me
my buddy
Glenn brought back up with you always
well I told him I always told him too I
go buddy I'm not bringing you to like be
a hero with me if this goes bad stand
near the door and if it starts going
haywire anyway get help sure yeah yeah
yeah like get out and get help this is
like everyone cell phone then and uh
yeah Runner was the same size as me by
the
way he's at the end of the block with an
inhaler yeah
J anybody got a butter roll what's going
B
what's going bad I need my
nebulizer nebulizer sounds like I'm
smart my parents are respiratory th I
grew up with a
nebulizer so um treatment they me us the
thing a white van pulls up and out of it
get guys who are uh they're a biker gang
clearly MH but the one guy standing like
I just see his like dick and Belt Buckle
in my window he's like follow us the
Bell is warlocks do you remember the war
the warlocks like South Jersey like
biker gang knew the name because my
exgirl ride my ex-girlfriend who was
trash uh lived in a trailer she uh like
she would always say her uncle was in
the warlocks like whatever yeah but I
didn't I guess they were a real thing
and they go follow us
easily a half a mile between a half mile
and a mile down a like dirt road to a
cabin in the woods of somewhere in South
Jersey D I would have turned around C
it's not worth it it's what are you
making a shift D it was crazy bucks 50
bucks you're nut and then uh and then uh
that include gas and tolls yeah the
girls tip they're supposed to tip you ah
right and they did but uh I also stole
their money often like he would be like
a gentleman no they didn't tip good for
what it was so I would definitely do a
little like 10 for them one for me so
they would so you would get paid they
would pay you I got paid $50 for the
drive no but I'm saying that and they're
supposed to tip you out later but they
would be like here's 10 bucks which I
get it they're fu stripper they need
their money for drugs or their kids or
whatever in that order I'm saying the
clients those are the only two options
the clients would give you the money not
pay the girls that's how how are you
able to G oh yeah yeah yeah that well or
or it was on credit card or something
already okay whatever was they would
tell me that and then I'd go in there
and either collect the rest of the money
from the guy tried to give to him I'd
get my 55 bucks I think it was right and
then uh the girls would make whatever
they make and then tip me it was if
there's a world where you don't do
comedy what do you think you'd be
doing dud I mean I always say working at
a g St but I'd like to think I'd like to
think I'd be like uh I probably would
have done what my parents did but I
really was so bad at school and didn't
like it at all uhuh that I probably
would have taken me forever to get like
a two-year degree and just work odd job
I don't know I was never think I was
ever like where I was like I'm putting
effort into you know what I mean like
going I'm going to do this thing and
it's only for 25 bucks but it's a 2 and
1 half hour drive but I have to do this
for this reason driving with some weird
headliner or something yeah so we I
drove down this dirt road to this cab
and we go in there it's it's a bachelor
party I guess but it's like all bikers
and when I go like in the bedroom one of
the bedrooms there's like like guns on
the bed like people put their jackets
when they show up to the party check
your weapons wild yeah and then
everyone's being nice bunch of leather
vest and shotguns everyone's being nice
though and then uh and then all of a
sudden like a lady like the girls are in
the bathroom changing into their
stripper [__] and a woman comes out of a
bedroom like a fat lady in a robe and
she's like what like there's it's a
party and it's everything you think it's
going to be like loud Credence playing
no the che uh and they're loud a woman
comes out like she's like someone just
tiptoed into her creaky floor she's like
what what's going on out here and this
one guy who looks like a Sam Elliot in
mask he's like get the [__] back in the
room you you know he's yelling at her
she's arguing with them and then she
goes over to go to the bathroom and
knocks in the door and I'll tell you
what what the senses that I everything's
tingling on me where I'm like this is
all so bad and scary and we're not
prepared for this they've got an Arsenal
on a bed Glen they've got an Arsenal a
bed which by the way especially at that
Glenn's halfway down the driveway I mean
dude you brought a guy named Glenn I
don't think Glenn felt it either Glenn
was a tough dude uh but I don't know if
he felt the I think he was kind of like
o I'm coming along for the this is cool
I was already over the girls get naked
not that you wouldn't Peak the first
time you drove them but at this point I
was always knew I'm like this is scary
as [__] for 50 bucks man what was were
you paying Glenn I'd give him like 20
bucks like yeah come hang man and uh so
you're 35 all said and done oh yeah yeah
yeah plus then you got to fill up the
you tips and [__] yeah it was not worth
the money it's a it's a passion project
so so I drive uh these girls are in the
bathroom and the girl tries to go in the
bathroom the robe lady tries to go in
the bathroom and uh you know she's like
who's in there I have to get in the
bathroom strippers don't they also don't
feel the danger of this and they're like
[__] we're in here [__] off we're
trying to you [__] [__] she like
[__] you she's trying to kick the door
in Jesus and then uh the main guy the
Sam Elliot guy gets up and almost arm
grabs her and like shoves her back into
the bedroom she was in he's like get the
[__] in there then a skinny guy who
looks like George Thor good uh comes out
in tidy whes he's like you my old lady
or whatever and then the same Elliot guy
and him I mean lock it up and go through
the door of the bedroom and there you
just hear fight happening I'm looking at
everybody else and they're like they're
Brothers man just let them [__] sort
it out Jes then you hear the fight stop
and the uh the guy in his underwear
comes hauling ass out of that bedroom
and runs through the screen of the deck
like I mean through the double door like
bust through the screen and jumps over
the deck railing and runs off into the
woods Sam Elliot comes out cocking a gun
goes on the deck and fires three into
the night air Jesus the brother never
came back I don't think he uh hit him
but like he just decided to stay I'm
just going to hang in the woods in my
tidy way dies down he's also got no
pants on never came back the wife just
stayed in the room the rest of the time
I guess the the the old lady in the uh
robe and this guy's like all right let's
get this party going it's enough you
slowly you slowly reach over and push
play on the boom box try to
bring Everybody's
Free to feel you guys feeling good out
there tonight so who's the lucky
fella so the girls come out and do their
[__] double dildo [__] show no one
says anything the guys were actually
during the whole show like peachy they
were very and I thought it was like a
good thing like I'm like this actually
ended up being kind of turn around if
you're not the guy's brother everything
seems to be going pretty good the robe
starts making sandwiches and then the
girls the girls uh go into the bathroom
to change back into their clothes and I
think these guys are all being like
pretty nice up hey you want a beer dude
you know get and I'm like my friend
Glenn again I don't know if he heard
them joking I feel like it's say how
nice they were you heard joking but the
Panic that it turned in me he comes over
he goes dude I heard these guys talking
outside they're saying like what are we
going to do how are we going to [__]
these these [__] or something and I
went over and knock on the door I'm like
girls girls girls and then I mean we it
looked so funny like people escaping
people that aren't trying to stop you I
like sorry guys we got to go and the
girls like we're not Dred I go get in
the [__] get Chang in the car we got to
go we got and then the guys like all
right man you guys taking off like that
like we got to get out of here I'm sorry
man got 8:00 we got get one part I
forgot about that was when we got in
there I saw the the guns and everything
I call I go hey can I use your phone to
call uh my boss go let me know we're
here he goes yeah I call him and I go
hey man and he goes are they cool he
goes they're a biker gang aren't they
and I'm like
uh-huh and he's like go everything all
good I go not really
man and he goes what are there guns and
stuff and I was like yeah he goes well I
mean they seem nice enough on the phone
are they pointing them at you and I was
like not yet no and he was like yeah
you'll be fine man they already paid so
good and he just hung up the phone and
it just put me through that whole thing
K how about that liquid IV shout out to
liquid I visel gang if you don't know
now you know get on that liquid IV we're
talking about hydration gang when you're
out there doing your Christmas shopping
or when you're at the Holiday party
you're going to run yourself down stay
hydrated with liquid IV it hydrates you
quicker than water mhm it's now
available and sugar-free which they just
sent us and I'm sucking them back like
cough medicine liquid IV has three times
the electrolytes of the leading sports
drink plus eight vitamins and nutrients
to keep you going uh with just one stick
mixed with water you'll be hydrated two
times faster than just water alone I've
been a big fan of this it's great for
listen I'm not working out I'm not in a
gym that much it's great for hangovers
let's cut the bowl I drink it I chug one
when I get home after night of boozing
you wake up bada bing bada boom next
morning another one you're saling baby
if you're Sicky take that fantastic yep
you can grab your liquid IV hydration
multiply Li sugarfree in bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20% off when
you go to liquid i.com and use the code
garbage at checkout that's 20% off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo code garbage
at liquid i.com do it K but talk about
factor factor factor factor we're big
fans of factors ready to eat meals I
believe America's number one ready to
eat meal kit that's Factor do yourself a
favor get over there place your order
throw it in the microwave ready in 2
minutes or if you want to be fancy like
Kippy you throw it on the skillet amen
baby I love it it's fantastic I've been
using it before they way before they
were a sponsor they're great you just
two two three minutes and you're done
you're eating like a king over I got two
words for you cauliflower risoto baby
delous fantastic uh they got uh vegan
vegetarian keto calorie protein plus
meal options no matter what your goals
are factor can help you get there it's
fantastic it takes all the guessing the
questions out of it you go online you
can pop in what you want that week hey
give me two of these three of these I'm
a big shredded chicken taco B guy give
me 10 of them if you're traveling you
pause it you reup the next week cuz
we're on the road all it's it's easy
peasy they take all the guest work all
they take all the headaches out of it so
head to factor meals.com garbage 50 and
use the code garbage 50 to get 50% off
holy [__] that's code that's code
garbage @actor meals.com garbage 5 to
get 50% off to it what was the first car
your first personal car I think this was
a biggie in our area Honda Accord
hatchback yeah there you go that light
bluish grayish holy [__] everybody yeah
everybody had that was it automatic or
uh stick it was automatic that was
automatic I learned on Stick mhm uh so I
know how to drive it but like yeah that
was an automatic that thing was all
right man it it was all right any
aftermarket stuff in there CD player
speakers on that one I think I just used
the like the regular old like the CD
player with the cassette that went in
there yeah yeah yeah I did that I think
but then uh when I got after that that
got stolen Kurt mear got that stolen for
me sound like he did outside the laugh
house he parked it in a uh towway Zone
then we found out it wasn't towed it was
actually s Jesus and they found it in uh
cam to New Jersey ripped the shreds now
the things that were in that car the
time were so funny my first ever head
shot which one was stabbed into the
dashboard sh that sounded they go do you
want to see it I was like no that sounds
horrible you want to see it yeah do you
want to see it I don't a man imagine you
on a car and there's like a box of 300
big J original head
[Laughter]
shots he know they were trashing I said
a [__] joke book and so I see some
like uh some crackhead junkie on BET's
Comic View going yo being a fat white
guy crazy right y'all killing murdering
did you have any of like the classic
horrible head like you have like caution
tape over your mouth or like you you one
I think with a sledgehammer uh yeah that
was that was way too much later than
that no this was the head shots that
were like uh the one I put on the
T-shirt that's from the uh that they Ed
for my special like where I look like
Elvis it's pretty [__] funny you
could throw it up I know the one where
you're where you're looking straight and
you have like a soul patch yep that's
that's the one there it is yeah that guy
right there I got a bunch of baddies
dude yeah they asked me to do a I just
said yes to whatever they told me to
pose like man yeah that's why I like
candid shots now are much better sure
I'm the same way I can't pose for
anything give me a candid shot Jer off
yeah my real estate pose yeah but this I
mean you got the leather you got the Sig
in the mouth cuz you have to in back in
the day head shots meant something so
you had to get your personality through
the head shot caution tape would be
great I wish I would had one of those
there it is with the sledgehammer
Sledgehammer Meister shirt Sledgehammer
over the nck yeah I was feeling good at
that point I just got off tour with corn
that's a corn
shirt how going to say that Jagger M
shirt you got for free for sure oh yeah
I think it may have said my name on it
what was your first concert what's the
first concert you went to ever was uh my
mom took me to Westbury Music not
Westbury Music Fair uh Valley Forge
Music Fair to see uh shaana which I
loved from the TV show did you tell us
this before yeah she wanted to [__]
Chico wow yeah yeah shaana was a good
show oh yeah b b Bang yeah Bowser yeah
it was like a variety show you know now
you could either hire shaana or Bowser
or Bowser the two will not work they
won't work together huh heard are having
a rift these days too say I just watched
that uh I listened to it on Stern this
morning over like publishing [__] now
when they're 75 restraining order and
[__] like that and dicey dicey guys
can't stay no stay friends forever I
guess and uh what kind of car you
whipping in
now uh Grand Cherokee there you go are
you leasing that or do you own it I did
lease you leased it I did Lease Only
because uh I lease too yeah yeah leas
it's like if uh I don't need it in New
York very much so I just it for
basically Road gigs and like two mile
drives and you have it in a garage yeah
yeah Garage in the building on the
street it's it's the building's garage
basically there you go see that's what
I'm talking about pretty classy you got
a nice place now you got a nice
apartment yeah what kind of air
freshener you got in that jeep oh I
because smoke what I do is I don't like
the air fresh that sits in there all the
time they they die out or they never
work anyway uh what I've learned what I
used to use was I found out by accident
in a hotel room when I had nothing else
to spray Jesus foot spray will the
charcoal in it will get rid of any smell
what a dirt bag so forever oh yeah for
whatever re for whatever for the longest
time in my cars I would always have Tena
foot spray Odor Eaters man or or CVS's
version of
if I'm in a pinch shout out to them
because that markup is crazy for the
name brand you're not wrong it's the
same stuff but I'd spray that in the car
and then I started being like once we
were parking in a garage I started
feeling like they're like what the [__]
is this guy spraying foot spray now I'll
tell works great I'd love to say it's
all [__] for Breeze Air Breeze ain't
bad for Breeze Air yeah I smoke uh in my
uh spare bedroom you do but out the
window out the window it's it's I'm on
the like 27th floor you're smoking in
the apartment if you don't know about
Big J he likes a heater indoors wherever
he is no no no I don't I'll finally go
outside if it's like not terribly cold
outside it's freezing and the block I
live on is the windiest Block in New
York city so like going outside every
time for a cigarette is a lot so I'll go
in my guest room and open the window and
like smoke out the window there got in
there let tell you something I've asked
this cuz I don't want that to be the
case for Breeze Air dude right away it's
a smoke throw the butt out which is
important I don't keep you launched the
you you launched the butt out the window
the gods Earth lit like yeah 26 floors
that thing's not making it fire all the
way
down there's no chance if that hit
someone on the ground got burned I'm
like come on is that J up there it could
it could blow back and go in somebody's
house or somebody's apartment well
that's what they were saying how plan
that well by the way on the cruise I did
that by the way a couple times I flicked
it off the boat and you'd see it it go
way out I had mine go up yeah it would
come way out and then come back it was
pretty fun I dude I flicked one and I
saw it go up like three stories I was
panicked iared I thought they would come
and get you they would somehow know nah
you're ripping heaters in there how
could they someone goes the trajectory
they go that was cabin
706 Coast Guard pulls up Tuck pull you
over
so they start smelling your balcony
you're ripping heaters in the apartment
man rare but uh it's rare yeah yeah all
right when do you have to have one in
the morning you have one in the first
thing W up I'll try what I try to do is
rip that quick [__] in the morning but
some I'll go out that window and take a
few Puffs to get the ball
rolling but then I go outside and I make
my phone calls and smoke a couple
cigarettes I I chain a few make my phone
calls I chain about three okay on my on
my daily phone calls and then uh and
then go upstairs and then try not to
until I go to work again Jesus huh and
are you showering at night or you
showering in the morning you like to
stay clean you're a clean man I'm a
clean man but I try to get all my poops
out okay and then go so I go we go to
bonfire
generally 4:00 we have to head there
okay basically whenever I have to leave
to go do a thing I try to shower an hour
hour and a half before that is
everything still kind of geared towards
the night like what are you doing like
what time you waking up give me a time
you got nothing you got aage 10 o00 okay
that's not bad I think sometimes earlier
if I pop up but like you know our
schedules are all [__] whacked out
from flying and [__] too sure like I
slept two hours the night before
yesterday you know uh so you got to make
that up somewhere yeah yeah today I woke
up at like 11: something okay so you get
up at 11:00 you're in the apartment it's
a weekday you doing a breakfast some
times if Christine my chick goes and
gets breakfast stuff only guy I know my
chick real warlock Vibes you know
Christine my chick yeah goes I send that
thingy brought out for
breakfast if she brings back yeah she'll
she'll make something for breakfast once
in a while okay are you guys going to
the grocery store on the regular on a
regular basis or is most of your meals
when you're here still take out or
deliver take out for a very long time
neither of us cook a lot and when we
it's just like the timing wise is so so
she works a ton too you know right so
like uh we ordered out a lot now we're
doing the factor meals shout out to
factor factor I dude I I found them
maybe two or three years ago I started
them before they were even sponsored
yeah I started like uh maybe six months
ago how many you taken down how many
have you taken down we do dinner just no
I'm saying can you can you eat two he'll
eat multiple in a city oh I could do
that but I think I'm try I'm doing I'm
doing the factor meal solely for the
gotcha like
contained in that little sure yeah they
are good as [__] though man they are
good the problem with any kind of thing
like that and I said they're sponsor of
us too they're [__] delicious for
what they are that's I'm saying they're
really good however though it is just a
time where you're like man I'm really
hungry I don't know if I want a bunless
beef stroganov burger with you
know [__] or whatever it's just like uh
Toby cut
this there's a great people over there
in factor I genuinely what I'm blowing
away in two-minute microwaving how
delicious it all it all is it's high
quality I'm just saying it's like the
choices made even though you make the
choice yeah I'm say about that I'm
having a hard time like you know I have
to really talk to myself to be like H
goes I'm I'm feeling Chinese food
tonight but I guess I'm going to have
asparagus risoto with beef tri tip cubes
or something CH but when you eat it it's
always but as a bigger guy we you know
all of us we you like to it's kind of
the Allure of like will I do Chinese
will I do pizza will I get a sandwich
the fact that you're constrained to what
that's what healthy people do they go oh
what's in the fridge all right I'll have
that we're like oh my God I'll do a
chicken I'll do two chicken porm hand I
don't even like I get like shitty about
leftovers of food I was amped up to
order the night before CU oh we'll order
Chinese food then we have Chinese food
for tomorrow too the next night you're
like I don't want Chinese food much more
out there yeah there Chinese food go I
at Chinese food last night now I want a
burger are you not that big of a
leftovers guy like depends on the kind
of leftovers depends what it is well you
take leftovers from a
restaurant an Italian restaurant
probably only really I think only yeah
yeah I don't think I'd bring home from
like a Mediterranean Place Mexican food
travels shitty yeah it does get all do
gets all mixed together it's over it's
just I've anytime I've had Mexican food
deliv outside of Taco Bell who's really
figured it
out I can't I mean that yeah okay dude I
was I lost 30 lbs eating Factory meals
yeah and the amount of times that I put
the factory meal unopened back into the
fridge to order Taco Bell I mean I bet
oh just the [__] feeling it's so
good I know but it is such a it's so
funny you look at the thing it's like
you picked this when I picked it I was
like pablano beef ball for that but if
your mind is like chicken fingers like
pablano beef bowl God damn it if you saw
a commercial or somebody was talking
about something that day and it gets
into the brain you're you're [__] well
with well it's also the best me I want
the pablano beef the best version of me
I'm like yeah I'm going to have a 500
calorie meal that's perfect I'm going to
make it in 2 minutes it's already at the
house it was but me if I do a day of
whatever and it's like oh I need oh I
need pasta to feel better today yeah but
I also have like the I'll I can reward
myself for the most minimal amount of
work like if you [__] like uh earlier in
the evening you know when you're done
you're like I mean [__] that was like I
really gave a lot like I could have
Wendy's
now like I'm not saying it's going to be
a net uh positive but I mean like it's
each other yeah yeah it'll be like I
never ate Wendy's because I [__] for
the better part of 15 to 20 minutes what
is the uh what's the silverware
situation at the house you guys got a
full
set yeah but I I'll tell you what when I
was growing up my entire
life when I moved out with my I was
living with my ex-wife forever and now
with Christine
Forever at some point every every couple
years we buy a set of like nice we're
like oh These are nice ones let's get
these
ones I think it's because we eat so much
takeout and [__] you just Zing those
things out constantly and you don't even
realize they just disappear you're like
why do I only have two forks oh they
must be in the dishwasher and you're
like there's only two forks in there we
have so many Forks like where and they
just throw them out with like for sure
like tin foil rappers of that is funny
it's also something about the mentality
if someone just took a factor meal
and somebody goes dude I'm ordering from
my favorite place tonight for us I don't
even and they just delivered it in like
a tin you'd Crush like think I would
just be like yo can I order from this
place again it's some the factor you
know in your mind you're like I know
making the I'm making a healthy choice
so and healthy is not fun like I had a
long day and I deserve to feel it's the
worst I never understood that like it's
like when someone doesn't like porn
you're like what when someone doesn't
have that when like like Josh adamy is
great guys great shape right or Justin
silver if we go to like Wawa together or
something like
that uh and we're driving back from
Philly all they're thinking about is
they're like they start opening it in
the car and they're like I can't what do
you mean you don't want us to eat it in
the car I'm like why do you want to eat
it in the car like they want to eat it
like right then in the car I'm like
don't you want to ceremoniously put it
on a plate and pick exactly what you
want to watch from WWA just whatever it
is I just I just want to ceremoniously
do you know what I mean like
different multiple dopamine hits with
Factor meals I almost get annoyed that
my uh that my girl puts out like place
mats and you know we get the forks and
I'm like this feels like I should just
be eating it over the sink and then
throw it out like throw the tin out in
the thing she plates them and stuff and
you're like what are you doing that's
classy no I know but I mean it's classy
that's what they did that was a a
European Vacation remember like slaping
from the microwave put a flag in it but
they uh no it is but there's something
about like again it's not making the
choice always Kippy you like AA frames
every every lady in my family's get one
for Christmas this year do you need a
nice holiday idea get yourself in Aura
Frame send it to Grandma all right you
got the pictures right there you can
upload them she's seeing fresh pictures
with the kids doing how he's doing in
baseball Bobby's playing gymnastics
doing whatever it's fantastic yeah uh
they were nice enough to send them to us
I got one at the house I got ended up
getting them for my mom for her house
there everybody throws a picture at
kitties up I'm getting one for her Shore
House Down in Wildwood bam take that
double up cuz it's such a good gift
everybody Mother's Day too yeah don't
I'm double dipping uh and it's if that's
not personal enough for you you can even
upload a video message to play on the
frame as soon as they plug it in so the
first thing they hear is your voice baby
we're bringing families together over
here in AA uh listeners can save on the
perfect gift by visiting Ora frames.com
garbage that's Aura a a frames.com
garbage use promo code garbage to get
$30 off their best selling frames terms
and conditions apply yes say you're
you're at you know you're leaving night
of
shows
you're headed home you stop at like a
McDonald's or a Burger King or a Wendy's
are you're taking that home into the
house 100% of the time yeah and are you
plating that or you're eating out of the
bag on the couch I'll I'll eat on the no
on my tummy while watch on the road
you're talking about even no in your
apartment here we don't really do it
like that but yes we well we eat on the
couch always couch your watch T going is
there a dining room table or a kitchen
table at the apartment no there's no
space there's no place where it would be
okay there's a kitchen counter that's
got like stools but like you're not
weird place to eat d a guy who sits at
his own bar and eats is psychopath yeah
so now we put we put like the place mats
on the Ottoman and uh just eat on that
okay basically will you plate the
McDonald's or no you'll go right out of
the bag out of the rapper Christino
bring plates for McDonald's which is
kind of
funny like what are we doing [__] what
are we doing stop it because she likes
to mix her stuff on the plate so she
makes she's a big we're a big sauce
household okay and she's a big sauce
concoction so it's like she has May the
ketchup she has her half hot mustard
sauce half ketchup for fries and Nuggets
she's got her whatever yeah like ketchup
over here to dip the burger in maybe or
so it's she's too I'll just eat those
right at I'm like no no no God made
these perfect we don't need to [__]
dress it up with a bunch of Schmutz do
in the car at
all if cuz I got to say that is done
with kiy that is a little I'm surp if
you go to Wawa and you're driving back
to New York well I'm I'm driving also so
I really can't I'll eat it in the
parking lot I'll pull I pull up in front
I will get my sandwich I will move so I
don't get judged by the other people and
go park along like the side or something
if I was eating for sustenance it just
wouldn't be that thing like if I eat in
the car it's like we got gas and and I
ran in and grabbed like you know fruit
nut mix or something you know what I
mean or worse than combos yeah I say we
here J I grab the fruit nut mix fruit
nut mix oh Christine might grab the
fruit nut mix I'm grabbing nacho cheese
pretzel Combos and if you eat cracker
combos you're a psycho get out of here
with why do they make do you know some
places have you ever been to a place
that only has the cracker combos only
the cracker I'm a pretzel combo man the
pretzel the orinal look like dog treat
they do they look like pepperoni thing
pepperoni fuing pigs in a
blanket and the red yeah they looks so
bad is that garbage my favorite orderer
of all time pigs in a blanket it's the
only one I can't miss love them I love
them it is trashy though I feel like
they you know I was at I was at a nice
wedding not too long ago and they had
the like dude I couldn't identify Endor
pronounce what all the other ones were
but they had the pigs in a blanket I
think is like a kitschy yeah like oh
we're you know we're trashy we're
sluming it and I dude I was clocking
them out of the [__] you as an entree
I like it someone Tri to fancy up a
basic thing the the stand the first
location of the stand used to have corn
dog popsicles they called it but it's
just a corn dog mini corn dog on a long
piece of wood like a long stick that's
all it was but $13 you get six of them
or
whatever flash fried corn dogs all right
all
right settle
down got corn dogs on the brain I know
there's something in here I forgot I had
a [__] uh ankle I forgot I had an
ankle
gun this guy the guy's got a six shooter
on him little nickel plated [__] pistol
down there oh you guys thought you
patted me down but I had ankle done the
whole time go ahead hit the door comes
out of your
wrist you got a cleanly over at the
house are you guys cleaning the house
yourselves we clean ourselves off but we
do have cleanly come in probably like
once every three or four weeks nice
Swiffer yep
Roomba no Roomba I the place is just
like I feel New York apartment just too
small to like make it make sense like
for me it takes to vacuum my whole
apartment which I have to do a lot we
have a dog you're doing this too you'll
vacuum yeah I really I clean I like it
clean I probably have even a higher
standard of clean than Christine does
see it's interesting but he's got blue
ha I when I am doing the things that I
require that she probably just wouldn't
do at all uh when I'm doing them I
really always have some part of me is
always feeling like you should be doing
this I take care of you very well and
why am I vacuuming but I want to done
right I want to done often fair enough
so I'll jump in and do it though but I
mean yeah she like she makes the bed
every day and that's that's a whole we
have like a special vacuum that vacuums
dog hair off the blanket and [__] which
is like it's it's an ordeal king size
match
California King California King okay
temper Pedic temper Pedic and it bends
up all right wait really yeah do you
have a TV in there 70 in I in the
bedroom [__] what the [__] sleeping
at at AMC oh in my living room I got
like a in my living room I got like a 90
something inch I my you have a 70 in in
your bedroom that's passed down from my
step pop my some my step pop his sign of
like we're doing all right yeah was like
our TV got bigger M and then when they
would get like a bigger or better TV
when I moved especially you'd get theirs
uh and they had a one of the last times
was a
Mitsubishi I mean speaker on the bottom
box big screen those things were huge
and when I my first or my second
apartment I guess New York Oh you mean
the monster flat screens yeah yeah yeah
that but it's they had the on on the
floor two feet deep yeah the bottom is a
speaker yeah yeah wait roughly 2 to
three tons yeah yes and I got a truck to
go pick it up for my parents Mike veon
came with me and Mike he'll he'll never
forget the story either it was like okay
how are we going to get this up was one
two three Jesus three flights of stairs
maybe four was and this thing was the
width of the landings and stairs and Vey
own somehow drew the straw for bottom
anchor and I was you got to do thatv
pulling and when my fingers came off
this thing dude I mean it was like uh he
should have had like the Stallone pal I
mean hey though he almost died three
times that night trying to get that
thing up the stairs we finally got it up
there and you know it's like one of
those things like it's outdated in a
year I don't even remember how we we
might have just left it when we moved
and been like no no actually we did we
we we moved it to our next place after
that Jesus that's our big bottom base
screen TV but so I said that the
technology changes a lot but my step Hop
was me so when we got like a place with
a wall that can fit I'm like I'll
sacrifice something to have a TV that
fits this wall 96 that's what you're
bumping out yeah I think so 90 95 96 70
in in the room and both bedrooms 70 in
that's the size of the bed that's crazy
that's I mean yeah that's and when you
so you'll sit you'll lay is it at the
foot of the bed yeah so you'll put the
thing up like you're in a Shay's Lounge
zero
g me the dog and Christine just sitting
there watching HBO Max original
documentaries were you were you eating
there were you EA in the bedroom no no
eating in the bedroom no when we
were once in a while we'll call it a
picnic and do it in the bedroom but as I
get older how much I love cute I don't
know what to tell you how much iess
romantic how much I love and I know it's
not a good way and I probably hurt for
it later but in a hotel room late night
eating on my tummy over my pillows while
I'm watching my computer is the best for
me you like that that's crazy I love it
but everyone's like I can't eat on my
and the more people tell me they
couldn't possibly eat on their stomach I
start paying attention to the reasons
why and I'm like you're probably right
it's probably a weird path for the food
to travel yeah imagine you're kicking
your feet like you're talking to boys on
the phone sometimes he's got the cord he
I do when we do Legion of gang Zoom if
I'm on the road when I do it I do it
we've done one with you you see my
little tootsies like kicking in the back
like a mermaid back
[Laughter]
there tummy
time that's crazy man H H what about in
the shower you using um you want to take
one are you using bar soap or you using
uh gel I take a guess gel loofah guy so
CVS loofah first things first I got a
it's a loofah glove wow okay uh so it
doesn't cu the lofas I feel like they
come apart immediately they do they're
like scrunchies yeah they're they're
sort of like that's when you know to get
rid of it but I feel like that happens
like in two or three uses I scrub yes
what are you doing the pots and pans
with him so I got this glove he's in
there with an SOS
pad uh okay I'm big on exfoliation but
so got great skin are you big on the
glove you talking about the two gloves
no no no this is one glove you know the
ones I'm talking about though they're
thinner it's fingerless oh yes I've done
those before too it's just glove they
like little winter gloves yeah but they
exfoliate the [__] out of here those are
good I like those but no this is just
like a one looks like an oven mid almost
okay but it's uh it's rough like a first
basement's glove yeah do you travel with
this no b no b no b no B I don't travel
with the glove talking to Christine with
it over your mouth I'll tell you the
pass me my cigarettes I'll tell you the
uh the two versions of what I do
depending where I'm at when I'm home my
shower thing is water pick
uh teeth get in the shower okay so
shampoo hair condition hair don't rinse
it out leave the conditioner conditioner
in then I brush my teeth in the shower
which we talked about before a big thing
brush my teeth in the shower then I
finish that then I mouth put the
mouthwash in in the shower in the shower
you have the bottle in there yeah then
who I've never heard lerine oh yeah what
color Peg Peg purple purple man I or the
all whitez or the all white the all
white bottle I don't know the color not
using the old school the yellow [__]
remember that when it C was like [__]
tpen now it's called sepol or whatever
like it hurts brutal but I pegged you
for a scope man no line this is a man's
man man's man and then um now get back
to your exf while I'm
mouthwash that's when I get the glove
squirt the dove fragrance free okay uh
oh I have very sensitive skin fragrance
free oh yeah yeah yeah so I use that
scrub the [__] out of my inner thighs
under gut armpits arms ass ass crack
[__]
feet then I put that down face grab the
dove unscented bar of soap okay and then
do the whole body with the
soap uh hit all the skin with the
soap then put that down put on a face
cave face like not Scrub but like you
know no like uh just face wash we're
still in the shower still in the shower
I don't know where we're at we're in the
shower still face wash I think there was
a slice of pizza somewhere in
there I uh do the face wash ma'am is
your husband
home have a have a factor meal sit down
have a
factor it's cut it's two slices of
sausage or something two potato
wedges uh then then I uh rinse
everything off then I take the shower
head off and turn it on the Jammer mhm
and I try to loose I try to relax my
[__] and accept some in there okay so
I could really clean out my [__] good
uhhuh uh I hit all the crevices with
that to power wash it out uh turn that
back off and then I get out of the
shower then the lotions Jesus Christ T
AC in foot spray is this even in the
summer you're lotioning and all that
stuff you're moisturizing in the summer
yeah yeah really all right so you do Tac
and foot spray every day yeah you're not
supposed to do that man you're only
supposed to no do you have athletes foot
all the time no and he never will either
kids won't either after nor will his car
when I went on those tours and I was
taking showers and like and I realized
that we do this a lot in uh hotels also
I got the I didn't know what the [__]
now as a as a fat guy I've had thigh rub
issues before where you're like that's
that chafing yeah this was wasn't that
it was whatever it was uh I had like a
thing that was King me on my inner thigh
and then I looked at it and it had like
a like circle around it almost which
wasn't like the rubbing or whatever I'm
like what the [__] and I went to a
doctor and they were like ringworm uh
yeah which is
essentially putting your underwear on
before like dry drag your underwear you
drag your underwear across your feet and
then you're pulling basically athletes
foot into your croch who so that's and I
was like oh never again so
tanakon
uh socks first socks first naked then
sock like your naked socks go first
first sock cuz you can't move around to
tanacon on your feet otherwise it's
going to wipe off I understand but not
even just that I just do the socks first
also so when I put my underwear on I'm
not
dragging like anything from my feet up
now where are you doing this you get out
of the bathroom or you're not putting
your socks off in the shower uh you put
your socks on in the bathroom no no no I
get out of the shower how many towels
you using TT lotion just one it's a
sheet bath sheet uh man I like a large
one and uh makes me feel Teensy he's a
monster on stage but lady in the
bathroom how much it overlaps when I
close it makes you feel nice when you go
to [__] hotels and I look like a a
gay bath house owner welcome everyone
sorry part of my balls hanging out are
you going above the boobs when you when
you wrap yourself up in it or you going
I go under gut the same as my jeans
nice in case I see anybody you can like
suck in and be like yeah my waist
actually isn't all that b make feel
skinny they make skinny you start
looking in the mirror like this and
stuff yeah I stand sideways go this is
how my stomach always looks I probably
always suck in um and then I'll uh yeah
lotion any kind of uh ointments or
whatevers sometimes I'll throw and if I
take a peek at it I'll throw on the
recta Care on my [__] so I don't it's
you living at CVS is this a daily
routine no I had a hemorrhoid once
someone said rect theare was a way to
play it cleared it up in a day and I was
like so now sometimes like the TAC I'll
just pop it on and be like you know what
czy [__] a little bit tender today
might as well throw a little reticare on
there just in case you're the only guy I
know that's had one ailment once and
just go every day is like I'm
do to that that's paranoia there's
something to that you don't want to get
the things again so this is a daily
routine yeah all those creams and salves
Sal a creams and sales hour and then I
put on uh socks underwear tank pants
shirt shoes you're doing a tank top
every day do yeah wife beer or like tank
top wife beer no matter what black wife
beater every day you are a dirt bag
totally
totally yeah black wife beater I'm like
a superhero I wear my [__] outfit under
my clothes at all times what do you
minut take my shirt off and then put a
tank top on afterward I'm going look
like an ass it Feats the whole purpose
of the tank top is that also
preventative maintenance so if you do
end in a frisky situation you're
completely covered let me tell you
something frisky what if we're in I just
watched Stallone's daylight yesterday
what if we're underground and surrounded
by fire in a tunnel and it's hot and
everyone's taking their shirt off cuz
it's so hot well I got to be able to
take my shirt off too and not be fully
embarrassed I mean dude so tank top cuz
I still even feel I go I think we're
going to die down here guys that guy's
got a lot of stretch marks I I don't
think we're going to die guys man are
those tits are [__] pecs guys I can't
breathe wow dude daily tank top in case
it pops off
anything pops off yeah literally
anything post-apocalyptic [__] uh a [__]
sesh could be a loose stripper or
[__] terrorist ready it could be it
could be a time where I just have to do
this
um what way Third
Street just got a little itch on my tum
tum there goes what up you guys singing
for dinner huh Jesus oh man you're nuts
can I tell you something [__] and
taking off my sweatshirt to start [__]
and the tank tops coming up with it is
the worst moment ever so you T you're
tucked into the pants Oh I yeah but I
tucked into the underwear no but I tried
to you're haven't pointed up in the 80s
the 80s he everywhere man he would be
getting late if he was I don't know what
this guy gu all over the road taking the
shirt off if the if you know the tank
Top's not tucked into the thing and like
having to do this move like the ho down
you get jammed up when you try a hoodie
on like a Macy's or something dude
you're [__] like try it on right here
it's just a shirt go no
I need a changing room can you unlock
four please thank you I just have one
item um so everything is everything is
in
preparation yeah hairs last okay and
then I I did not know this about you
it's not that's a that is a huge routine
man and some would say it's classy your
reasons and paranoia are not yeah yeah
yeah it's all rooted in trash [__] yeah
what are you put in the hair that's got
to be that's you you like you have a
nice head of hair you take care of your
hair it's got to be a good product if
you're doing all that other nice product
and hold on are you washing and
conditioning your hair every time you
get in the shower now yeah with uh
should stop that short hair it's not
good for you for short hair I don't
think it matters very much when I was my
hair every
day you got to treat it right for one
month look what happened well how often
do you do it I wash my hair maybe once a
month no yeah it's thin though it does
but it it does it gives it like that
kind of shine and makes it lay nice yeah
he's not wrong but also the thing is
what are you putting product in your
hair every day yeah you just rinse it
every day I rinse it yeah and but you
don't wash it no yeah I get it wet I
would say pull off a couple days a week
and see what happens I might give it a
shot I'll tell you what gets ring worm
on his head God damn it don't listen
tell you got good hair full I'm going to
give it a shot and I'll tell you cuz
what I don't like is if I don't put
stuff in my hair I have like just like
not frizzy but just like just awful no
I'm saying use the product use the
product
out yeah you might want to you might
want to pull back from the especially in
the I don't know if your scalp gets dry
it also depends on whether your your
your hair's oily no I you know what's
funny I had dandruff once in my life
when I was a kid yikes and one I just
you know I didn't know how the extent it
was but I used cuz that was again this
is the hair products of like I did
spiked hair when I was younger M with
the tail and uh Dippity Doo was what I
was told to get which is just alcohol
and cl dries if you touch your hair it's
instant dangerous so I had I didn't
realize how bad and then one day doing
homework over a composition book I
remember like I did the uh the allei
shitty from The Breakfast Club and with
a mechanical pencil like the with no
like lead in it I started going at I
mean I basically de flaked my hair which
was crazy and then got selson blue and
put that on my hair and I mean screamed
for that stuff burn so I just attacked
my head with a point you know what I
mean it hurts but uh I never had dandr
foret after that for some reason I
always try to use better products use it
three times a day every day my product
answer that question before is uh right
now it'll change time to time if I find
one that's but crew Crew fiber fiber
good fiber is my base layer Jesus and
then there's like I forget the name of
the other one if I saw it I would spray
or crew forming cream the green one the
green label it's not forming but it's a
different kind of cream it's it actually
might be cream and it's like a grayish
but it's the stronger hold but what
uh what you try to get is like the I
don't like when it like when you touch
it it's like spikes and they hard like I
like to be able to even though it's like
done to still be a yeah so I put those
can I touch it sure curious oh that's
nice way softer way softer than you
anticipate it cut grab it all yeah it
looks sharp okay man but I'm going to
try this less washing I would do once a
week when I had long hair okay I'd wash
once a week but you're right the fourth
day of like uh not washing it though
you're like it's the best day it looks
yeah it is but something about me new
I'm like it's greasy though yeah but
like it does shine yeah it's good like
the natural oils get in it do you put
the conditioner on your beard do you do
anything to that I have beard shampoo
conditioner in my but that was given as
a I would have never bought that that
was given to me as a gift how often is
that in their routine like every other
day when I'm home any blow drying no not
anymore but uh when uh again on the road
my big thing is this is nuts we've spent
about 40 minutes in the bathroom I know
crazy
nuts that's crazy dude your [__] tree
dude and the the on the road I bring a
bar of soap so I have my Dove you do you
bring a bar of soap is it a fresh bar or
is it in a thing I always have a fresh
bar in my bag full size full size
waiting in or the dollar one but but the
good soap though good Dove but I keep
one in my suitcase like full ready to go
and then I have the case that's the
wearing down one from the road oh those
things are so trashy the soap container
they really are garbage but it does feel
even though it's like a buck thing for a
bar soap I'm doing it it feels something
so weird about like cuz I could just
leave it there which I've done before
but I'm like it's just weird to keep
ordering it and packing it to like leave
it I've been I've been if you were
bringing a clean bar of soap with you
every time you would be a cereal killer
and I was doing that and I was like it's
kind of stupid so I don't do that
anymore I bring I always have a fresh
full unopened wipes in my bag butt wipes
yeah but I will also bring like I will
work that one down until it's gone like
on the road and then I'll open up the
new one on the road so I always have
like one plus you always have a Jesus so
when they have the body wash shampoo and
conditioner in the shower like in the in
the little thing you'll never use that I
use the shampoo conditioner
for sure yeah in fact it's uh it's so
yeah it's shampoo conditioner and then
what I have started using now because
I'm like I never LOF on the road I'd
like to LOF now I'm not bringing a
loofah but it's where I've now learned
the beauty of thank you black people the
washcloth are you can exfoliate with
them so I do a washcloth whatever their
body wash they have on the thing is so
you will use that I will use it but
here's the thing I don't really go I go
armpits uh arms
[__] dick
pits and feet that's really it then
everything else I just do with the bars
I don't know anybody that washes their
feet I've never heard the term dick pits
yeah the pits you know what I mean yeah
oh it's perfect it's clear is the de
what deodorant is that going anywhere
other than the
armpits we use a little little under the
belly you ever do that it's not a bad
idea but uh I do Under the belly not
that but I'll tell you what to do
instead of that if I may please please I
don't want to step out of
bounds but uh you're the cleanest guy in
here consider getting yourself some the
girlfriend's in this now too she does it
for thighs and like under tit [__]
gloomy no um Armen
Hammer baking soda No Gold Bond spray
okay Gold Bond spray and that does work
my problem with the Gold Bond spray is
the aerosol runs out quicker than the
than the product in it does it I had
that last summer well I was using it uh
under the under the under the hood so
when I turn it upside down the medicine
wouldn't come out it would just be the
Aira yeah that's when you have to trust
a woman to spray it from behind while
you get on all
fours or get some sort of pulley system
yo hit the carriage for me real quick
there she is you're a good
kid now get out of here get out of here
SC huh wow what kind of
deodorant uh the
degree like prom is no white marks sure
so it's antient and deodorant I think so
yeah okay yeah it's got to be I also but
I get B I get BOTOX in my armpits whoa
for the sweating rules really yeah and
it's so funny I don't have like uh like
I'm not a huge like sweater I really am
not like I don't sweat it like you know
like Lewis like sweats so much uhuh I
don't very much but then it would just
get times like on my armpits like I
would hate like I wouldn't want to wear
like the shirt I was going to wear on a
show on a drive if it was like an hour
sure cuz I'm like just sitting in the
car like up I'm yeah I'm I'm shitz in
now I'm telling you if the botox it
takes what's that set your back two
minutes insurance will do it what like
yeah nothing this guy's getting cosmetic
armpit
surgery but it makes you stop up well
you just hyper hydrosis which I don't
think I have but like if you if they say
you have hyperhydrosis they'll do it it
takes 3 minutes and it lasts like a year
doctors play a little more ball now than
they used to they really do pay to play
they they they they always really say
I'll make sure I type this up so it
works for the insurance company oh I
you're not wrong I do believe my doctor
if like he's also a fan and a great dude
but I think if I was like I'd love to
try some opiates you'd be like all right
back
certain man I
mean I'm more confused I'm
sorry that he's a clean guy
you said you're using the water pick
yeah no flossing floss in the road I
don't bring the water pick floss on the
road and the flossing is a daily thing
yeah the sticks or the actual floss
you're brushing your tongue I don't
think I can do the sticks anymore cuz I
got the veneers ah so uh do what you say
you brushing your
tongue no uh uh yes I do brush my tongue
but I was told the other day you have to
get a tongue scraper which now would
become part of the thing it was Ralph
from a gas digital Real gross when
person said it's disgust you have to
really RSE it off like after you do it
it's like a retainer smells so bad yeah
it's not good but your tongue feels
great it does right yeah it's also I
think it's like supposedly very healthy
for like your gut and like it's like a
very like for the rest of your body I
think there's benefits for it I got a
tongue scrape now add that in jum it
down for me these guys never going to
get out T scraping too Cal yeah really
it really that is the annoying thing
between the time I said taking a shits
my Rio like let's see what's going on in
the world what am I going to talk about
on broadcast today time so I really make
a meal out of that I try to get out now
when my legs go numb I mean you're Nots
dude because I heard that's really bad
for you it's not good I used just let it
go when my legs go numb I would just
shift cheeks and just like let that I've
never had I'm in and out to a speed
where it's like it alarms Toby Toby's
like I've never seen anything like that
you do move quick in there that's my
moment they're trying to get you that's
my moment are you a Squatty Potty guy no
yeah me neither I'm I tried more of an
explosive diarrhea soda swears by that
thing I they're good for you I know but
I didn't seem to make any difference for
me other than it just feels weird the
way I'm sitting was it was it too tall
cuz cuz you know there's there's levels
there shorter ones and taller yeah I got
it my we didn't realized it when we
ordered it and we ordered one that was
like [__] 4 in yeah I feel like I was
in the Apollo Space Capsule legs were
like up
here the baby floating in space who am I
in a [__] Udo um taking your shoes
off on a
plane uh exclusively when it's the lay
down ones that's given and I overthink
also one of the things I forgot in my
routine also is uh Arm and Hammer now
also has a sneaker refresher spray so
every time I before I put on and take
off my sneakers I'll spray that in the
sneakers
very and the thinking of that is also
because like I said it's fear as a been
fat my whole life so I've
never wanted to be the smelly I've met a
lot of fat people who like even like
Comics through the years I've met where
I'm like I feel terrible cuz like me and
this person have so much in common it's
same like why are you letting yourself
be like the smelly [__] guy I'm like
you got to choose one or the other man
you could be a gross [__] bony thin
guy and chicks won't give a [__]
sometimes you need every you need you
need to win every battle you can that's
why I said I don't know like have you
are you guys big on like like I was
always impressed with soda's a person
who could do this and several other Josh
hadam Myers does all the time people who
are relatively confident in like their
thing in their own skin just ripping ass
in front of chicks oh never never I
would I'd be so mortified I'm like Oh
and it stinks of course cuz you're fat
and it's something gross down there yeah
yeah I have I'm so like worried about
[__] like that I had a buddy in college
in shape good-looking dude and I wasn't
even that big you know I would go
through phases like I'd be skinny in the
spring I'd be heavier in the winter but
I was I was a fat guy I was a chubby guy
this kid was [__] shredded blonde
gorgeous and he loved it he would be at
a party and just [__] rip one and
then [__] laugh about it and I had to
pull them aside I'm like dude they think
I'm doing it you got to knock that [__]
that's your anxiety no they you know
what I'm talking about exactly if
somebody in room by assumption unless
the person takes the full like ha look
at me credit for it it's a little bit of
insecurity I'm going like they probably
assume
so whenever like so I try to never put
myself in a position where if someone
goes like oh what the [__] is that I
just forg even saying it out loud I go
it is probably not me I'll tell you what
how B I show three times today how bad
it gets this weekend Cleveland Ohio
something I don't know if they were
cleaning the room or something
afterwards or maybe it was a trash but
something smelled like [__] and I know
that I had a little bit of bubble guts
so I was like I think when I get back to
the room I am going to [__] I didn't
didn't fart or anything but I just kept
smelling and I was talking too was with
me and I'm talking to him about I'm like
do you smell he's like I do smell I go
buddy I don't hang on and I went into
the bathroom by the way the only
bathrooms that hilarities are public
yeah so when you go in there three
people go dude no [__] way I go
myself I go hey what's up guys and I
went in the [__] all they saw was me
go in the in the
stall uh undo my belt uh put a piece of
toilet paper down and swipe it down my
ass crack nothing there mhm and then so
they heard me go in there for a second
they heard
like and then two seconds later me
walking out being like what's up guys
thank you man thanks for coming out and
then just walking right back out of the
bathroom I clearly didn't piss or [__]
it look like I went there to do Coke it
was so bizarre but I went to take a
swipe in my ass to make sure before I go
meet people after the show you didn't I
don't have [__] in my cheeks well that's
anytime as a also no [__] way that's
the best
oh the guy was like no [__] away I go
hey guys what's up sorry I got to beine
I may have [__] myself and not known it
uh wait that was your genuine concern
that you would [__] yourself and didn't
realize it I have that a lot cuz I was
just like I couldn't even guess where it
would have happened but I was just like
that smell was strong and I was like and
I equate and you start small thing I go
I have like bubble guts F maybe I just
like let it out and I and not knowing
somehow I am getting older and you start
you start doing that of like concerns I
had a lot of weight on my plate I was in
the elevator by myself I didn't smell it
then so by by assumption it's not me I
didn't smell it in the Uber I like you
start doing that math and then coming
back in the room when I realized it's
not when I went and wiped my crack like
that I came back in the room now I'm top
investigator on what it is all
right let's go through let's see what it
is cuz it ain't me and now I'm going to
shame whoever it
is yeah that was the fat man's whenever
another fat kid would have something fat
happen to him it's devastating other fat
on fat crime dude there was no
solidarity in that the other fat kids
never went leave him alone man it's
[__] embarrassing you you [__] you
can't your fat feet can't walk in front
of each other down steps poor bastard
some fat kid at the bottom bleeding ah
you dumb fat [__] I'm not as fat as this
guy right girls I used to start fake fat
there was one kid that came to our
school Jesus I don't remember even if he
was I don't think he was fatter than me
but I was like I just made a a lie I'm
like that kid so fat like I went up and
I poked his stomach with a pin he didn't
feel it which wouldn't even be the ca
your nerves are still
there it's not your skin between you and
any pain in your
stomach I love how you're like new kid
on the Block I got to get out in front
of this I got start you got to control
the one kid I ever tried to bully dude
end up [__] like teeing off on my
face cuz I the we were fighting outside
of uh the
library uh by a school that's where
everybody kind of went to fight and then
uh it start I was picking on him I was
like trying to get him to like [__] I
was like all the cool kids were like a
little behind me going like yeah dude
you know you [__] with this guy and
that kid came and uh he threw his
[__] hat up in the air he just had
enough of me like doing I was I was
doing it cuz he was not accepting so I'm
like oo I can lean into it like he
doesn't want to fight I don't really
want to fight I just want these kids
think I'm cool and then he turned around
and zung his hat up in the air H and
like a dummy I went I looked at the hat
and he hit me it wasn't too bad and then
I just had him in like you know what we
all did in school the most no real Mo
next move headlock back to F guy
headlock yeah oh are you done are you
done hopeing he gives up you good you
good we done and I don't want to hear
about this ever
again and I'm I got him in the f I not
doing any damage just holding and then
the security guard comes out and he goes
hey I already called the cops so you
guys better get the [__] out of here and
I was like oo my mom's not going to my
mom didn't play with that so I was like
I we're done here I just let him go and
started walking with my friends and he
jumped on my
back thank God on the you know Philly's
like uh it's like curb grass
sidewalk we were on that grass thing
thank God cuz he just like uh the crying
kid in uh Christmas story he's just
wailing and and grabbing my hair and
like banging my face thank God in the
grass you know what I mean and it's just
me for but I can only assume was 40
seconds going okay it's over I'm done
went home
embarrassed you don't told them I fult
uh didn't get in trouble for that cuz
the cops didn't call and then but I do
remember like the the less I've never
done that again like bullied
somebody at least you know through
school andu or watch somebody's hat go
in the air graduation you're just follow
the Hat I yell at when I see other
people do it don't follow the hat trick
the book trick is Old As Time so um
that's crazy but
uh I remember going to school the next
day though and being and me and that kid
never really became friends or anything
we were fine but like uh I remember more
like I just went right back into
whatever my resting place was in school
by those kids even asking me like dude I
was [__] up he jumped on your back and
you gonna [__] him up now you G I was
like no it's done man like I I don't
know if you heard I'm over it I went up
to that kid and I was like that was dumb
I don't really have any issue with you
and [__] let's just please like let's
just drop that it wasn't even like I was
afraid of getting beat up again he
turned around he jumps on you again he
yeah he go he goes
absolutely Even Stevens what's just
behind your
ear cloth
line a all righton we got to wrap it up
um is that an hour I mean yeah it's well
over an hour I was hoping take a note
big J part
three we've gotten to like we I love it
here I literally come here every month
once a month to do this well let's do it
we didn't even get out of the bed
bathroom but a lot of that was me I'll
make it here a lot of that was very
classy
anybody with me on this the I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure he sticks his
finger in his [__] if we're being
honest with you we I do stick my finger
up my ass but to clean it sure I get in
there heavy and then I also have one of
those four-way uh nail things to make
sure there's no dookie on my nails oh
the brushes okay you're using that in
the shower as is the uh it's it's like a
file and then smooth and buff are you
filing your nails yeah well you know
what funny that's got to give him some
points right well no I'll tell you why
talking about trash move nuts dude well
I'll tell you about the trash uh move I
forever forever bit my nails off I mean
down to they were n they were crazy
looking a lot of them don't grow right
now because I bit them off essentially
they were they were it was crazy and
talk about high strong yeah I mean it
was guy just randomly thinks he [__]
himself all the and then I got the
veneers you can't bite your nails so
this is the first time I life in my 40s
snap off it's just you shouldn't they're
so hard Nails you're not supposed to do
that can't put pressure on them like
that it's probably the reason the reason
I got veneers is cuz my front two teeth
kind of like crossed over a little bit
and I feel like that was because it
almost like the perfect pocket how I B
my nails gotcha so like uh I can't do
anymore so now for the first time I have
nails
and I have uh scratched inside of
[__] I've done all kind so I really
I'm like oh I have to really take care
of these like again also cuz I bought
them I mean I bought I bit them so much
like it does change the so my nails like
if they get like a little long where
yours might just look like a long nail
mine starts like coming up almost just
like they're just like not the right
shape Jesus so I trim them and I file
buff
smooth shine what are you doing what are
you doing with the toenails you you you
you just cut them Clint with cpom nails
how the hell hell do you have time to do
nine podcasts it's
crazy the [__] pretty much I'm getting
ready for podcast and do podcasts that's
my schedule you're literally getting
ready for a wedd you guys want to play
sports ladies and gentlemen Mr Big J
oerson till next time Baby a true one
and only ah yes I I do want to share on
the creu um you were the last show of
the cruise of the last night mhm and we
hadn't watched watch uh I we had you
know we hadn't watched any comedy on the
cruise and we were like Jay's [__]
Clos in Jay's the last show we went and
watched I was like let's go watch five
minutes you know what you don't really
watch comedians that much dude we sat
there and watched you for an hour and it
was it made me it was like one of the
moments I was like I was pretty [__]
up I'm not going to lie I was like this
is pure happen I was watching he was
dying we were dying you were killing you
guys man means a lot coming for you it
was so [__] it like reinvigorated me
uh watching comedy it was [__]
fantastic controlling the room and just
[__] sitting back and just [__]
murder you guys pulling lines out to the
point where like dude we were laying on
each other laughing so funny I mean it
was so crazy so cool to see one of the
absolute best check out dog belly if you
haven't checked it over there on the
YouTube page listen to Legion of skanks
listen to the SDR show this been volume
two of course the the bonfire H you're
coming back you change tapes and put in
volume three now our first double CD
Mr Big J oerson everybody K what do you
got for him guys we're still all over
the road closing up the tour uh we have
DC coming up get those tickets at the
Howard
Theater I had that other ankle gun this
guy came in strapped to the
gills couple of Shooters on
him oh God we're uh we have DC coming up
the second show with the Filmore and
Phillies almost sold out if it's not
already get them tickets uh we [__]
love you gang see you next week gang
peace peace